okay let's dive into some audience
questions if you want to submit an
audience question then I invite you to
do so ideally using the contact page at
david pakman.com but you can tweet it
post it to facebook what else is there
you'll figure it out you can get us the
questions first one is from Betty Betty
says hey David one of the funniest
segments I remember you ever doing was
weird funny or odd reasons that people
canceled memberships or wouldn't become
members in the first place it must have
been years ago can you update that I
actually have some really funny new ones
and some that are just kind of
disturbing so here's a funny one someone
wrote to me not long ago saying David I
love your show
agree with your politics appreciate what
you do but I will not become a member
because I do not want to support your
bachelor lifestyle I'm your age and I'm
married with kids and there is no reason
whatsoever that I is someone who's
married with children should be taking
money out of my pocket and putting it
into your pocket to support your
bachelor lifestyle they just seem
jealous well that aside it's just like
is the program worth supporting or not
and can you afford it right if you can
if you have a family and three kids and
you can't afford to support independent
media that's okay I mean the show is out
there for everybody for free I don't
need you to support it
if you have the money to support it
regardless of your family's situation
and you find it valuable then I invite
you to make a contribution become a
member be make a patreon pledge whatever
but saying merely because of their life
situation and my life situation that I'm
not married with children that thus the
program is not worth supporting whatever
I mean it's it's fine everybody is free
to do whatever they want but it was one
of the funkiest ones I've gotten ever
especially cuz it's not like you're
living some deplorable lifestyle you
know and gonna be spending the money got
for membership in some untoward way oh
yeah but like guilded I don't even know
what things were gilded because I've
never bought anything gilded glassware
hours I have no good lizard but Trump
Tower gilded Trump Towers exactly right
okay so there have been people over the
last month or two that have canceled
because they don't support Nicolas
Maduro and Venezuela and I've been clear
I don't support
the non-democratic regime of nicolas
maduro more common than you might think
i think a handful or maybe even ten
people have canceled because I don't
support Nicolas Maduro as you know if
you've been watching the show or
listening for a while I do not change my
political positions in order to obtain
or retain members that sort of defeats
the purpose of being independent media
also some people wrote to me angrily
saying David um fibromyalgia is real and
I have it and it was so rude when you
said it doesn't exist that I'm
cancelling my membership and of course
that was a misunderstanding of what I
said
what I've said in the past is that there
are eight to ten conditions that while
they are of course real many people end
up being sort of diagnosed with them
when in reality what they have is an
emotional issue that is manifesting
physically and I've talked about my
history with headaches that were really
just stress headaches and I went down
the garden path of figuring out what it
is that's going on headaches are common
back pain is a classic back pain people
start going down the full garden path
and oh you know what you do have a
little bit of a slipped disc here and
that's probably why your back hurts and
you get an operation and of course that
was never the cause of the back pain in
the first place all fibromyalgia is on
the list I'm not saying these conditions
don't exist and I'm not making a
diagnosis of any particular person in
our audience I'm not a doctor I'm merely
talking about there are conditions that
tend to manifest in people of particular
personalities and very often those
conditions are not actually caused by a
physical injury but rather because of
emotion and stress and anxiety that is
in someone's life it just seems like
some people discover the show and start
washing for weeks months on end yeah
agree with the majority or the vast
majority of what we have to say but then
we get to one topic yeah there's some
disagreement and all of a sudden they're
not gonna support us as of course
there's and the thing is they just hate
us overall I could not possibly let's
say I made it the policy any time
someone threatens to cancel because I
took the wrong position on an issue I
will revise my position on that issue
then someone else will cancel because
their position no longer agrees with
mine I mean it's not a way to run a show
it's just not a way you my view is
either you value the existence of the
show and you generally believe that the
ideas we espouse are aligned with yours
and thus you support the program or you
don't but the anybody who's willing to
say I hope that you don't take the wrong
position on X or Y issue you're bound to
at some point be disappointed and cancel
your membership because that's just not
how the program works it's always funny
when someone writes in saying yeah I'll
become a member as long as you do like a
sports segment or a relationship segment
I mean we could calculate that out that
just wouldn't be worth it to us I mean
to change the trow the show entirely
human decisions that way for one
membership can't make decisions that way
no we and we don't and you know what I
think most of the people 99 percent of
our members they support us because
that's not how we run the show I truly
believe that